vous êtes tous là depuis longtemps pour
certains et ce soir j'ai décidé de faire
venir pour chacun d'entre vous vos sosie
on a lancé un appel pour avoir le
meilleur sosie d'entre vous à chaque
fois et on va démarrer avec mon premier
saut le premier sosie nous vient de
marseille
il a 37 ans et c'est mickaël hanouna
regardez c'est mon sosie
regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
dans l'autre coderre
merci à toi on va se battre comme ça
parce que tu es magnifique halle et non
les mecs enfants de bloquer ce que tu
peux mais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais
ouais
ah ouais frères sas tu connais un lot
n'est pas mal le plus beau c'est quand
même
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à marseille et je vais bien méritée et
est beaucoup plus beau que moi non
franchement assise juste dix ans -
serena n'a été trompé sur la fiche ah
ouais t'as qu'à l'afr 35 ça on est
battus fait beaucoup plus que toi ah
ouais quand même mais était battre à ton
avis on doit avoir la même mère ou le
même père s'est d'entrée reconnaître a
reconnu le gâteau ou pas oui à la mersey
le même merci attention on a maintenant
le sosie de valérie bénaïm à l
assistante de direction du côté de
sarcelles elle maîtrise aussi bien le
beau shing que valérie regardez la elle
est là sonia le sodi nova les lecteurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et elle a l'air aussi sympathique que la
très belle et merci des choux un jeu
c'est de poser de de sophie favier
surtout grave c'est vrai les deux c'est
magnifique j'adore vous êtes très belle
trêve si jamais ça c'est du coup ça fait
que moi aussi donc c'est vous êtes
contente d'être le sosie de valérie
bénaïm très fier il ya déjà des gens
dans la rue qui vous ont dit oui
très souvent c'est vous et vous quoi
bein je connais bien puisque j'ai un
resto crainte du coup j'ai plus près non
c'est fini
quoi tout le monde vous appelle babau
and we gonna renom de suite c'est vous
l'a déjà dit a way of automatiquement
oui on l'a déjà dit mais donc maintenant
c'est cyril tout le monde faisait pareil
chez vous on vous dit valérie ou pas
mais on ne dissout pas vraiment mais
vraiment c'est incroyable je fais de la
télé mais aussi du coup je fais de la
télé j'avais fait quoi ben comme vous
connecter à votre mère vous prendrait sa
place un jour vous inquiétez pas ça
variés et du coup ils vous parlent de
moi rapport à siri jamais alors on a
maintenant le sosie de gilles verdez il
est au beurre
il est auteur compositeur sur paris il
est moins bruyant que gilles et
s'appelle luc regarder luc verdez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est ce qu'on prend pour cible dans la
rue la voix n'a rien à voir non pas que
j'ai mal à ma france
ouais j'ai du mal à ma france toute mon
équipe ou ressemble mais c'est
magnifique c'est dingue mais aussi pour
moi il ya quelque chose attention on a
maintenant le saisit de kevin kelly elle
s'appelle mélissa elle a 21 ans
ah et puis gène quelques années alors ne
suis rien du tout une broutille à cet
âge là elle s'appelle mais lichaj
impensé mélissa bezo v10 regarder mes
dix années
[Musique]
mais non
oui
tu dois côté mettez vous reconnaitre
pour kelly bout du tout achat désert
jamais vous a jamais prises pour qu'il a
pourtant elles sont bonnes alors ça vous
êtes content non mais on est franchement
pour l'instant je trouve génial c'est
pas mal et en plus je vais vous dire la
vérité pour la plupart les saucissons
nucléaire oui il arrive à quai ou mais
vous l'avez trouvé où 1
mais attendez vous croyez que je suis
dans la rue un appel est prêt nous a
répondu merci mais dis ça en tout cas
attention à eux alors là sur la tête de
ma mère
le sosie du jab helmand ibos je vous le
dis elle à 57 ans elle s'appelle muriel
lé chauffeur livreur de pièces
automobiles à l'ats beat elbeuf elle est
là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça va mieux
franchement mettez-vous à côté c'est à
ça qu'on appelle une fois oui non qu'ils
sont a dit pas que je veux faire sombrer
tout simplement ni les biens jambes
merci c'est sûr j'avais mes très content
mais on va faire un échange de boucles
d'oreilles à bernard morel qui en train
de décider il pas dès qu'il est plus aux
uv des couffins on va passer la
sociologie de géraldine maillet elle a
48 ans elle est conseillère européenne
sur paris elle s'appelle anna elle est
la regarder elle est très belle
c'est à part
[Musique]
on dirait des soeurs anna cette manif on
dirait nécessaire nous a été dit que
vous ressembliez géraldine maillet non
mais quand j'étais plus jeune on prenait
souvent pour sabine azéma en tout cas
vous êtes très jolie merci d'être venus
merci merci à
il avait la possibilité d'être le sosie
de bruno le maire a préféré la
difficulté non arrêtez avec ça je vous
demande alors il a 29 ans assad m bien
il est fonctionnaire à paris il est
fonctionnaire pas il est très beau
presque attention comme j'ai un petit
peu tendance à coucher narcissique mais
c'est la fanfare son père la jeune
serbie demandé je ne sais pas contents
qu'on lui demande en direct écouter il
est là il s'appelle bertrand de leur
mois
[Applaudissements]
c
[Musique]
oh
tu penses
[Musique]
mais c'est tout
bon
oui avant d'aller vous la cabab ouais
franchement incroyable et c'est
magnifique
elle m'a pas du tout bon victoire alors
du tout non le radar est planté et
planck rate le radar à mon ami à merci
lambert croyable eh bien on s'était déjà
rencontré oui oui tout à fait savoir
bertrand ouais ça va bien cela n est que
l'agression pour bertrand ouais pauvre
combien tu fais de cette fille par jour
0 mais on me le dit souvent que testeur
jours ça vous fait plaisir de ressembler
à matthieu delormeau ouf
si franchement après enfin il pas des
bassins non faut pas se le cacher mais
pas des glaces mais bon je préfère avoir
son physique ou son mental son physique
comme je vous comprends
merci merci j'aimerais bien avoir le
sien c'est de quoi le physique
ah oui non mais je veux dire il vous
plaît vous plaît ah bah vous vous êtes
célibataire
oui mais c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
alors il va attention à a alors il est
très beau gosse et dj du côté de toulon
où là il est sexy c'est pas maxime alors
non c'est le sosie de maxime donc un
sexy ouais c'est john gay ni regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette fois
moi
attendez mettez moi quand même été bulut
ah ouais franchement 30 55
il ya un truc que vous ressembliez à
maxime galy pas trop un patron mais
c'est vrai qu'en regardant la comme ça
j'en connaisse pas chi minh et bartoli
on lui dit souvent tu ressembles à john
alors il est allé passer de aa à
jean-michel mais un aventurier
professionnels et life coach en fayotage
pas vous c'est lui parce qu'il faille
est aussi oui c'est patrick dont il
aventuriers regardez la [ __ ] cannes
c'est patrick mère 58 ans
[Musique]
ça va
honte à régaler faire là bas il est très
dégradé les beaux gosses regarde le
corps tu peux y aller ensemble de parcs
j'ai vu toute une batterie côté coda ça
va un aventurier
franchement c'est un autre bail un peu
gras non non mais thébaux était bien que
tombé au bon franchement t'as les toits
qu'on regarde mes classes se ressemblent
pas du tout non mais là franchement rien
à voir quoi attirer le père patrick très
patrick pour moi c'est logiquement ça va
j'ai une période calme ça peut arriver
célibataire patrick oui je suis
célibataire ou dans les soirées on me
dit souvent arrête de faire de jean
michel donc c'est très bien que mal
elle est allée à l'équipe et je craque
là à nous ici
ah ouais c'est vrai alors attendez qui
alors très vite qu'ils vont pêcher
patrick mais alors qui a dit daniel oui
vous d'accord
eh ben on va quand même pas très rapide
tournez manège je vous le dis c'est
complètement con faisais mes trois
premiers rangs tu peux passer derrière
merci patrick tu sais quoi patrick tu
vas pouvoir ils vont me poser chacun une
question beau sourire il centrait -
j'adore patrie alors moi je vois là non
annoncée du sert et on peut voter
l'année prochaine et bien sûr été conclu
pour l'année prochaine patrick tu fais
coutu est un aventurier toi chez
aventurier et je suis homme de radio 6
puisque j'ai une émission radio sur le
bien-être
ce matin j'ai été de 7 heures à 9 heures
en direct mais une radio il serait bien
le ballon mais n'at il eu option
commencé sans ribéry oui nous manquait
sur le bien-être le sport et la
nutrition
[Applaudissements]
je pars maintenant j'attends dans la
quête mais c'est vrai que là il a eu un
gagnant et un coup dans la fourmilière
les questions alors on a vous avez vous
allez pouvoir chacun posez une question
à patrick c'était pas du tout prévient
il va répondre et à prendre alors choisi
de benjamin castaldi
vous allez voir c'est quelque chose
matthieu delormeau
oui bonjour patrick mathieu giroux line
renaud patrick si on dîne ensemble de
manière romantique et accepte tu qu'on
passe le dîner consul de guinée pour
justement sauter tout court directement
faire l'amour cas peut-être penses-tu
comme moi que l'amour c'est le réacteur
du couple aussi à cette chimie dans
l'amour le couple peut durer alors moi
je suis pour l'amour universel
en plus donc l'amour ouvert ah oui à la
bourse est rarement fermé universelle la
nature les hommes les femmes c'est
universel y'a pas y'a pas de sexe dans
l'amour universel
c'est une beaucoup plus intérieure c'est
parti donc c'est non
[Rires]
sinon allez et daniel isabelle
morini-bosc une question les femmes de
plus de 50 ans très bien entretenu oui
oui j'ai en plus j'adore les aventures
humaines et surtout avec des femmes de
plus de 50 ans
[Musique]
aya il avec s'est positionné je sais que
la voilà mais daniel à toi question et
sur les 70 ans
est-ce que vous être est ce parce que
isabelle étant mariée voilà donc est ce
que vous vous faites une formation
accélérée en sexe parce que j'ai besoin
et que je suis donc je suis life coach
et dans mon intervention je
je globalise mais attend de moi je
globalise c'est à dire je sais autant
sur la nutrition le sport le physique
éventuellement le sexe des loups
[Applaudissements]
adri que célibataire tu vas devoir
choisir et je sais que c'est pas pesé
puisque le soigne et vision it a proposé
deux fois quand même magnifique effort
mais là c'est encore bien là c'est
vraiment et on va assister à un suspense
tuco kg 1 dans un instant mattrick tu
vas devoir choisir une ou un depuis
pretoria préliminaire et donc il a vu
les deux autres peut être y parvenir sa
réponse très belles elles sont très
bonnes à giuly s'est effectué une petite
danse savais qu'ici c'est médias et
danses et chants et les banques
patrick après ces petits échanges avec
les trois qui choisissez vous si daniel
les célibataires c'est daniel
[Applaudissements]
m
patrick allées désertées
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
savas pêchu j'adore ces les deux raretés
tv dmb ses 9 ans d'amour et patrick
[Applaudissements]
alors est adressée ce pas qu'est ce que
tu fais ce cas là qu'est ce cas là mais
ça m'arrive
il est bon quand tu vois il est beau il
souriant il est intelligent il est
sympathique c'est un aventurier
je serai seul l'agent patrick est ce que
vous pensez vous allez vous revoir
oui pourquoi pas enfin juste à la télé
ou après oui en vrai avec plaisir mais
on sait qu'il vient halmos ramos patrick
tu bosses comme c'est pas nous
oui mais ce que tu vas d'armes des
poteaux public avec daniel oui alors il
ya alors merci françois qui est là je
serai content de le voir bien sûr qui a
vécu depuis le début on soit oui ces
sites
alors maintenant mais non non attendez
non non je dirais qu'on est dans
intervilles apparemment il ya des règles
réclamations de et je m'assure jaune en
s y est je m'insurge il ya cinq minutes
a proposé de passer la nuit avec elle et
je suis les châteaux qui n'étant pas un
homme facile jeune je n'apprécie pas les
des femmes faciles donc tu reviens pour
moi mais on peut faire ça 3 si vous
voulez que j'aime mais hier ils étaient
trop qu'il arrêterait rédaction des tv
câble sat hebdo et là maintenant frères
ils arrivent ici on fait un plan à trois
doigts d'avoir quelqu'un alors patrick
va avec daniel merci à ma mère elle lui
a pris les mains à base de main en crabe
[Rires]
ville on a peut-être assister là à la
naissance d'un amour pour l'instant j'ai
l'impression que c'est c'est
déséquilibré mais les fans en basque il
n'a pas aimé il n'a pas aimé
en tout cas bravo françois bien on voit
votre mentalité ne lui ces acquis la
série p chopin et bach personnes pécho
elle tarbes à celui-là les cherry on va
maintenant accueillir le sosie de
benjamin castaldi dernier sosie bon
benjamin sa chair c'est banon c'est
exact dont il m'a regardée voilà le
sosie de doha qatar
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d
le problème et il a un succès toujours
là un sourire hamas mais lui est allé
ramasser des gens beaux jean-pierre
franchement ça donne utah jambes savez
c'est par ici
mais profitez de faire un repas de
famille s'il est élu n'ait pas de veto
mais nous comptons dans son cas on sait
qu'il est plus grande que vous
maintenant je vous aime beaucoup mais
calmez vous reçu c'est ce qui m'énerve
le plus c'est quand on me dit tu
ressembles à ton fils c'est lui qui me
ressemble c'est ça c'est le serpent qui
se mord la queue
j'en perds tu as vu qu'il ya eu un début
d'année les deux là t'as vu qu'il ya de
l'amour entre dames érigé en marquer
voilà des séducteurs par ici à l'essai
du terra exactement alors les cherry est
ce que j'ai le droit de danser non pas
danser
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hop
[Musique]
il est aussi sympathique que son pays
n'aurait franchement s'arrête jamais
mais je les adore moi je laime
franchement je dis mais si toi tu
laisses ton va pas s'asseoir
merci on va dire est avec nous tout de
suite vous savez que cédric 6 heures
n'est pas avec nous
malheureusement aujourd'hui parce qu'il
travaille et il saisit on nous dit à
quoi ok c'est qui a oui c'est vrai qu il
ya le sosie de delphine wespiser avait
un défi d'aller où là la balle rentre
avec son sosie pas fait la rentrée à
l'état
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces lois à l'orge alors tu fais toi elle
saute sur jambes comme la désert sur le
moment je me sens rigoler on s'est dit
c'est l'anniversaire c'est des surprises
des cadeaux donc girondins voulu faire
ce petit cadeau à jean mi et vu qu'on
n'a pas réussi à se mettre d'accord
depuis des mois et cros g et ben du coup
j'étais amené florine
[Applaudissements]